high-pitched puppet let me just say a
quick hello to you because i've never
spoken to you before
oh i love it the high-pitched eric
puppet has yellow teeth
horrible tattoos are you driving
multiple cars
yes i have two vehicles now
yeah uh do you have a phlegm problem
like uh high pitch eric where your voice
gets like kind of
[ __ ] up from phlegm so the car went up
in the air
and i was driving yeah and they hit my
head on the top of the oh
on top of the [ __ ] yeah
sometimes certain words like
cream i have problems with
yeah oh man okay it's a tough one
and then when i get tired you know so
sometimes my voice draws that's a little
bad
i i'm wondering if i had you repeat this
sentence i wonder how many times your
voice would dip like that let me see
the rain in spain falls mainly on the
plane
the rain in spain
falls mainly on the plane
and i notice you have a very expensive
cuban cigar you're holding too
aren't you i love smoking
i love cigars they're so good
so funny because he stabs his face with
the cigar i don't know if he's really
smoking again
we said to the guy who makes these
puppets he's a real nice guy that this
was literally as fat as the puppet guy
could make it we sent it back to
the guy's office to have it made fatter
uh
because uh do it yeah that's why eric
looks so buff
he says i just this is as fat as i can
go i can't get that much fatter so
uh his arm is dying and ready to fall
off that's how heavy this [ __ ] puppet
is
will you be cutting any cameos i know
the real high pitch cuts cameos
are you going to be cutting cameos today
and what types of things will you say
uh i don't have too many today just 47.
right i'll pretty much
read whatever you want i could do one
right now i have one you want to get all
right
sure but just take us into your world
happy birthday you fat loser
wow